congrats on becoming a mama as well
that's exciting my gosh I will eat those
cheeks oh my gosh she's so cute he is so
cute in that jacket coming off the show
looks like an ad
um so how's your son doing he's good
he's a really incredible traveler he's
so social and friendly and warm and
loves to share he's a little bit of an
aggressive hugger but we're working on
it
um I think that's you know a quality
problem but he's so sweet and he goes
everywhere with me so I love that so
when you say like he had a wildlife my
kids grew up too they're good Travelers
because they kind of had to be right off
the bat but you grew up like that as
well obviously your dad like was it hard
growing with a comedian and him always
being on the road or did you get used to
it comedians are not funny they have I
think there a lot of comedians are
extremely intelligent and they they have
this weird vision and they use all of
their joy to make other people laugh and
then off stage but I also grew up around
a lot of my dad's friends and
um they always were really really funny
to be around but yeah I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
guys I'm going home
[Music]